You're going to answer the calls, the leads, as they come in, you're going to answer them live if you can.
Now, if you're somebody that has a day job or you missed the call, it's okay.
You're going to call the leads back, okay?
And when you call these leads, you aren't going to act like a lead generation company.
You're not going to, hey, my name is Nick with Evergreen and we're going to patch you in.
No, no, no.
You are just going to act like you work for a tree company or a concrete company or whatever.
You're going to keep it vague, okay?
You're going to call these business owners, or sorry, these leads, and you're going to call them up.
Say, hey, Janet, this is Nick with Las Vegas Tree Service.
Saw that you called.
What do you got going on?
How can I help?
Well, I was looking to get my palm tree removed.
Okay, cool.
How big is it?
Blah, blah, blah.
I'm acting like I know what I'm doing.
Okay.
What's your address?
Give me your email.
Okay.
And then you're going to go like this.
Janet, thanks for calling in.
I'm going to call the business owner to give you a call here in just a moment.
Let me get a hold of him.
I know he's on another job and I'll get right back in touch with you.
By the way, I'm probably going to be calling you from my cell phone, like the one I just called you from.
If you see XYZ area code, it's not a scam.
It's me.
It's just my cell phone.
I'm going to be on the move.
So watch that.
Okay, cool.
Thanks, Janet.
Now we go and we call the business owner and we do our cold call and we hook them.
We get them on the hook.
And I'm going to get into that whole script.
I'm going to call them.
We're going to say, here's the deal, Mr.
Business owner.
I'm going to give you three, four, five, whatever.
I'm going to give you a couple of free leads.
Okay.
And I know you want them because you're already paying for home advisor or you're already paying for Google ads.
So you're either allergic to money or you're looking to grow.
So I'm going to give you these free.
All I ask in exchange is we have a conversation in a couple of days about potentially, potentially working together.
Doesn't mean we're going to, but just let me earn that call.
With that, boom, that's it.